Matt Hancock would have known his first
appearance of the covert inquiry would
be difficult
but not as difficult as for the bereaved
families he walked past on his way into
the hearing
the evidence I shall give
shall be the truth the whole truth
and nothing but the truth
his line of defense was clear
start he blamed the system his fault was
to believe what he had been told about
the country's Readiness I was assured
that the UK planning was
among the best and in some instances the
best in the world the attitude the
doctrine of the UK
was to plan
for the consequences of a disaster
can we buy enough body bags where are we
going to bury the dead
and that was completely wrong
why were those practical
considerations not followed through
these recommendations were not there
because the system was geared towards
how to how to clear up after a disaster
not prevented
from testing to PPE to social care every
failure was according to Mr Hancock
systemic
when Matt Hancock walked through these
doors in 2018 as the new health
secretary warnings about an emerging
pandemic had already been sounded but he
says he inherited a flawed Health System
one that was worried about Mass
casualties and body bags and burial
space not with containing the spread of
the virus but there was more than one
attempt at an apology from Mr Hancock
his written submission when he said
there isn't a day that goes by that I do
not think about all those who lost their
lives to this awful disease
and again in person
I am profoundly sorry for the impact
that had I'm profoundly sorry for each
death that has occurred and I also
understand
why for some it will be
hard to take that apology from me I
understand that I get it but for
bereaved Widow Lauralee King
the apology means nothing I don't accept
his apology and most of the brief well
all of the brief that was sitting with
won't accept his apology either
lauralee's husband Vincent died in March
2021 after catching covid in a care home
the same Care Home Matt Hancock visited
before the pandemic she was with other
bereaved families where Mr Hancock
approached them after he gave evidence I
felt surprised it just really confirmed
for me the arrogance of the man
to think that such an overture would be
welcome
because it isn't and it wasn't
as evidenced by the fact that we all
turned our backs on him
[Music]
Matt Hancock comes back in the Autumn
when the inquiry turns its focus to his
and other senior roles at the heart of
the government's pandemic decision
making
oh she's Joshi Sky News